[Música]
a los 29 años tengo mi primer hijo que
comienza a tener algunas complicaciones
y después de ir a varios especialistas
fue el modificado con autismo
seguramente el 90% lo que está sentado
en esta sala tuvo problemas similares a
este problemas muy difíciles de afrontar
en la vida muchos de los que están aquí
han perdido algún familiar querido han
tenido graves problemas económicos
y han tenido o tienen una enfermedad
grave cuando pasamos por estas
situaciones muchas personas nos quedamos
sin ganas de seguir adelante o
simplemente nos gritamos en lo que
llaman la zona de confort que la verdad
de confortable no tiene nada pero bueno
yo necesitaba seguir adelante y decidí
armar un emprendimiento
pero no era la primera vez que pasaba
por una situación límite así a mis 14
años pierdo a mi mamá en un accidente de
tránsito
tres años después a los 17 años me
agarré corralito del 2001
y como no podíamos sacar plata pasamos
hambre durante varios meses
llegó un momento que nos juntamos con mi
hermano y nos dimos cuenta de que
teníamos que hacer algo así que bueno me
arremangue y no quedó otra que sabía
hacer changas corte pasto pinte rejas
hice todo lo que sea necesario
pero bueno la situación se puso más
crítica y llegó un momento que no quedó
otra que vender objetos personales muy
queridos como por ejemplo la caña de
pescar que me había regalado mi mamá mis
cinco años
todo esto para poder comer y mientras
tanto seguirá yendo a la escuela en
bicicleta porque no tenía para pagar el
colectivo
pero bueno todo esto que parece ser un
bajón y lo es me ponía una situación
críticas tan difícil tan dura que al
mismo tiempo me hacía dar cuenta de que
tenía que encuadrar mi salir adelante
así que mi a mis 18 años con lo que
quedaba el seguro de vida mi papá
decidió armar un nuevo emprendimiento
armó un gimnasio y nos comienza a ir muy
bien pasó a tener seis empleados
280 socios que pagaban su cuota mensual
generaba ingresos que mantenían a toda
mi familia
me van a ayudar con la administración
del gimnasio mientras mis hermanos
seguían estudiando todo iba bien
dos años después a mis veinte años
falleció y mamá un cáncer fulminante
un cáncer que se la llevó en 30 días de
los cuales yo me enteró que era cáncer
en el día 28 29
esta situación fue verdaderamente un
desborde que fue la primera vez que
sentí que no iba a poder seguir adelante
con desbordes que me estaba llevando
puesto pero bueno este mismo desborde me
pone como tutor legal de mi hermano mi
hermano de 14 años así que si o si tenía
que seguir adelante por él
pero bueno al mismo tiempo encima no me
renovar el contrato de alquiler donde
tenía el gimnasio
así que pasa un tiempo
consigo un muy buen trabajo de una
empresa multinacional me empieza a ir
muy bien y cuando me estaba por
convertir en el sub gerente y subgerente
muy joven una situación familiar me
llevó a renunciar
después de esto a los 28 años me estaba
estabilizando
pero bueno como ya les conté a mis 32
años con francos de tres años me dan el
diagnóstico de autismo
yo no sé lo que le pasa a usted en
situaciones límites pero a mí en
situaciones límite la verdad que me
salvó emprender así que si bien estaba
muy bien en mi trabajo en ese momento yo
tenía claro que volvería a emprender
pero con la idea de que volvería a
emprender en algo grande
siempre cuento que para esa época de mi
vida yo tenía tres cosas muy claras
primero que amaba lo que significaba
emprender pero con todas con todas sus
palabras era tan fanático que me la
pasaba leyendo libros de emprendedores
famosos leía todo tipo de noticias sobre
emprendimientos y era pero tan tan
fanático que me mire repetida como siete
veces la película de steve jobs
solamente porque me inspiraba su forma
de emprender
lo segundo que tenía claro en la vida
era
que me atraiga los emprendimientos
relacionados a alimentación
más allá de la condición de franco
siempre estuve vinculado a los alimentos
y si bien mi experiencia me llegó por
lado de la tecnología yo elijo emprender
en la alimentación
lo tercero que tenía claro es que el día
que vuelva a ser un emprendimiento
quería que verdaderamente ese
emprendimiento genere impacto en la
sociedad y en el ambiente verdaderamente
tenía decidido que el día que lo vuelva
a hacer iba a ser un emprendimiento de
impacto
pero bueno esta vez el que genera un
emprendimiento un nuevo comienzo fue
franco y su forma particular de
enfrentarse a la vida
frank costados para lindos pesos
productos de alimentarse mal
está batiendo problemas de nutrición por
algo que ya no podía manejar
franco tenía alimentación selectiva
producto del autismo esto hacía que
franco no coma carnes u otros alimentos
que por su textura o color no le
resultaban agradables
para colmo a franco tampoco el
resultaban agradables los complementos
alimenticios que vienen en polvo o el
líquido
pero saben que si había algo que a
franco le agradaba
y más allá de su textura o color a
franco siempre le agradan las golosinas
así ingreso un evento de la vl un evento
para emprendedores con la idea de
presentar este proyecto de golosinas
saludables a base de fruta deshidratada
mientras me piden que haga los primeros
estudios de mercado me chocó con el
problema de francos y ahí me inspira a
combinar la idea de golosinas saludables
con alimentos funcionales que
complementan la alimentación y ahí lo
tenía la primera golosina que alimenta
pero claro mi formación tras ser
incompleta la verdad que no me iba a
alcanzar para hacer semejante proyecto
tan ambicioso que buscaba ser un
complemento alimenticio con forma de
golosina pero que verdaderamente
convenza al niño con su sabor y con su
forma así que ingreso a otro evento de
la url donde ayudan a conformar equipos
de emprendedores
ay conozco a sandra licenciada
tecnología de los alimentos y auriel
estudiante de biotecnología que sí si
viene la estudiante siempre cuento de
que lo elijo a él porque veo que
verdaderamente cree en el proyecto desde
el momento cero
empezamos a trabajar en equipo y fuimos
premiado por la universidad
yo me enamoro tanto del proyecto que
verdaderamente me pasaba muchas noches
pensando cómo iba a ser para combinar
vitaminas minerales
probióticos y en este caso proteína
vegetal de origen agroecológico
con el equipo nos juntamos y comenzamos
a cocinar las primeras golosinas en la
cocina del departamento de urgell
en la primera prueba él se comió 30
golosinas si literalmente hubiese comió
30 golosinas
con esos prototipos ya listos nos
preparamos para hacer el desarrollo del
primer producto mínimo viable con la
idea probarlo en el mercado y con la
idea de salir a buscar financiamiento
porque hasta las experimentaciones son
costosas para un bolsillo emprendedor
es decir estábamos buscando hacer una
golosina que alimenta que es saludable y
que es cuidadosa con el ambiente
pero bueno ahí lo empezamos a enfrentar
con problemas como por ejemplo el
problema tecnológico
como hacía para estabilizar las
vitaminas y minerales en una golosina y
que no pierda las propiedades
empezamos a pensar en cómo desarrollar
una tecnología alimentaria que en la
microencapsulación
que hace que las vitaminas y minerales
justamente no pierdan sus propiedades
dentro del alimento
esta tecnología se venía usando en otros
alimentos pero no las golosinas o sea
porque hacerlo en las golosinas si es
justamente algo no saludable
por otro lado nos damos cuenta que
tenemos que aplicar ciencia ya que
tenemos que invertir muchísimas horas de
investigación y desarrollo para dar con
una fórmula de 30 nutrientes que
verdaderamente complementen la
alimentación de los niños sea
verdaderamente tenía que ser balanceada
como se dice para que aporte el
desarrollo y crecimiento de los niños es
decir estamos obligando ciencia y
tecnología en una golosina que en verdad
es un alimento
por este motivo tenía amigos que me
decían y se aplica ciencia y tecnología
la verdad que es comida astronauta
pero bueno también nos enfrentábamos con
otra sensación no sólo tecnológico sino
los desafíos culturales
cómo hago para explicar la papaya mamá
que la golosina alimenta es como decir
tengo un choripán que no engorda o tengo
una torta que adelgaza
como hago también para ayudar a la
alimentación si generalmente los padres
asocian golosinas con algo no saludable
y cómo hago encima para explicarle que
ese caramelo evita las caries
la verdad que no estaba fácil aunque
usemos pulpa y jugo de fruta aunque
pensamos usar conservantes colorantes y
saborizantes naturales
otra vez si estábamos pensando en una
golosina saludable que cuida el medio
ambiente que alimenta que no engorda que
te cuida los dientes es verdad una
golosina
pero bueno también empezamos a pensar
que verdaderamente podíamos colaborar
con la comunidad así que también tenemos
la idea de presentarlo como un aporte
que verdaderamente ayuda a organismos
instituciones que tengan niños con
problemas de malnutrición por ejemplo
por carencias económicas y poder
nosotros donar ya ayudar no solamente
eso también tenemos la idea de emplear
gente con discapacidad o con la
condición de franco que ya es donde se
originó el proyecto y verdaderamente
queremos generar un impacto
el mes pasado salimos segundo en el
evento de emprendedores más importantes
del país participaron cuatro mil
emprendimientos duró seis meses y esto
no validó como uno de los proyectos más
importantes a nivel nacional fuimos
declarado de interés municipal y
provincial y tenemos tres empresas muy
grandes del país interesadas en
colaborar con nosotros
yo no sé si ustedes pasaron hambre si
perdieron un familiar querido o si se
hicieron cargo de la vida del herido
pero si están dispuestos a seguir
adelante a enfrentar la vida y
encuadrarse con la gente que ama
seguramente tiene una parte resuelta o
por ahí como me ocurrió a mí quizás las
dificultades familiares y un caramelo le
salvan la vida muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]